الشاشه
[تصفيق]
تظاهرات الليليه في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه واضراب النار بمقر للبسيج فيكم
روسيا وايران تعترف بارسال مسيرته الى
موسكو قبل الحرب
صواريخ اسرائيليه دمشق
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
انطلقت تظاهرات الليليه في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه مردده شعارات مناهضه للنظام
فيما احرق المحتاجون مقرا للبسيج وصوره
لقاسم سليماني في مدينه
رامز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في الساعه 10:00
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سيدالي
يا اخويا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قال ايضا على
المجتمع الدولي التعامل مع ايران كما
يتعامل الناتو في اوكرانيا
تكثيف العمل
العسكري والاستخبارات ضد ايران قبل حصولها
على النووي وفي هذا الشان من قال وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه يتوجه على المجتمع
الدولي ان يجمع بين القوه واستعراض القوه
في التعامل مع ايران
قال نائب السفيره الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده روبرت ان الخارجيه الايرانيه
اعترفت بنقل طائرات مسيره الى روسيا وان
الادله واضحه على استخدام روسيا لهذه
الطائرات في قصف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
اليوم
2231 ارتكبها عضو دائم في هذا المجلس
وكشفت اوكرانيا
ايرانيه
اعترفت في نوفمبر الماضي بنقل سيارات الى
روسيا ودعوني اذكركم ان القرار
221 يحضر نقل هذا النوع من الطائرات من
دون موافقه مجلس الامن المسبقه
اما السفير الايراني الامم المتحده امير
سعيد ارواني فاقد قال من جانبه عددا من
الطائرات المسيره ثم نقلها الى روسيا قبل
اندلاع الحرب داعيا الى وقف حملات الاتهام
والتظليل بشان استخدامها هذه الطائرات في
اوكرانيا
مع اوكرانيا
فان ايران نقلت عددا من الطائرات المسيره
الى روسيا قبل اندلاع الحرب ولم يتم نقلها
لاستخدامها في الصراع الدائر في اوكرانيا
لذلك يجب انهاء حمله التضليل والاتهامات
ضد طهران والتي لا اساس لها من الصحه
اقر الرئيس الروسي بلادي ميرفتن بصعوبه
الوضع في مناطق دوناتس ولوجانس كوا خيرسون
وزبا روسيا وبوتين طلب قوات الامن في
المناطق التي ضمتها روسيا قبل اشهر ببدل
قصارى جهدها لدماء ضمان اقصى درجات الامن
واحترامي حقوقي وحريه المواطنين
الى تعزيز عمل الاجهزه الامنيه في
المجالات الرئيسيه وسط ظهورا او ظهور
تهديدات جديده
بلاده بمجموعه واسعه من انظمه الاسلحه
لتعزيز وتوسيع فعاليه دفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه
لاوكرانيا سيزداد في العام المقبل
خلال العام المقبل بنفس الزخم او حتى
بالدفاع اكثر وهو بالضبط ما نحتاجه لتعزيز
عملياتنا الدفاعيه نحتاج الى المزيد من
المدافع والقذائف والى الدبابات الحديثه
التي لم نستلم منها بعد بالاضافه الى
انظمه الصواريخ طويله المدى وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي الحديث والفحاله
وضع وزاره الاتحاد الاوروبي او وضعوا
اللمسات الاخيره على اتفاقي ايطالي
حول تحديد سعر السقف الغاز المستخدم في
صناعه الكهرباء عند مستوى 180 يورو
ميجاوات الساعه
الاليه تفعل اذا تجاوز السعر السقفه ثلاثه
ايام متتاليه وتدخل وحيد التنفيذي في
منتصف فبراير المقبل
اذا تجاوز السعر في الشهر المقبل وفقا
مؤشر تي تي اف 180 يورو للميجا وات في
الساعه على مدى ثلاثه ايام عمل ثانيا اذا
تجاوز الفارق بين السعر وفقا مؤشر
الاساسي للغاز المسالي في السوق العالميه
للغاز اذا تجاوز الفارق 35 يورو على ثلاثه
ايام عمل
اليه تصحيح السوق السوق
بعدم تفعيلها اذا واجهت دوله واحده صعوبه
في امدادات الغاز او اذا ظل السعر في
المستويات
الخاصه باليه تصحيح السوق مثل ما اقتراحته
المفوضيه لكنه يقتضي حزمه من الض القويه
المفوضيه تعتقد ان هذه الاليه مفيده لكنها
تتضمن مخاطر لذلك وضعنا ضمانه اضافيه
لحمايه مصالح مزودين غاز الموسال والسيوله
واستقرار اسواق المال واستهلاك الغاز
المجر ان فردت باعتراضها على الاتفاق
النمس وهولندا تلتاهما احتفظتها بصوتهما
احتياطيات والغاز في السوق الاوروبيه بلغت
مستويات قياسيه
96% بالتالي لا خوف من شتاء هذا العام
المشكله تكمل في احتياطات العام 2023 حيث
سيعاني الاتحاد الاوروبي عزا من الغاز
المسال بنحوي 30 مليار متر مكعب حسب تقدير
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه ما قد يحد من تاثير
اليه تصحيح السوق التي حذيت بالمصادقه هنا
نور الدين الفريق العربيه بروكسل
يلتقي وزير الطاقه الروسيه
مع نظيره الايراني عليه اكبر محرابيان
لبحثي تطورات الاوضاع فيما يتعلق باسواق
طاقه العالميه ومناقشه وضع العقوبات
العالميه على البلدين وتفاصيل بشان
المفاعل النووي الايراني وتحديد اسعار
النفط والغاز الروسيه
قالت وسائل الاعلام
في المنطقه المحيطه بالمطار بعد وصول
طائره شحن ايرانيه المرصاد السوري لحقوق
الانسان بدوره قال ان اربع انفجارات شديده
دوت بالقرب من مطار دمشق الدولي
مزرعه تقع بين السيده زينب
والمجدليه ما ادى لتدميره بشكل كامل
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
القضاء التونسي يصدر قرارا بسجن رئيس
الوزراء السابق علي العريض
اهلا بكم من جديد اوضح رشاد العليمي رئيس
مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني في مقابله
قناه العربيه قال ان جماعه الحوثي تهرب او
تهرب المشتقات النفسيه الايرانيه الى من
من الحديده مضيفا ان عشرات ومئات شركات
الصرافه تتعاملوا مع الملكات
هناك
الشركات
التابعه للمليشيات الارهابيه همم التي
تقوم بتهريب
المشتقات النفطيه الايرانيه الى من
الحديده
هناك عشرات او مئات محلات الصرافه التي
تعمل مع الميليشيات
هناك الكثير من
البنوك التي تتعامل مع هذه الشركات ومع
هذه القيادات الحوثيه الارهابيه
الاجراءات بدات اتخذت الحكومه والمجموعه
من الاجراء
الحوثي الان بدا اااه
يصعد امام المجتمع الدولي
ويقول لهم ان هذه الاجراءات ستدفعني لا
يعلم الحرب ما هو معلن الحرب اصلا
في ظروفا معيشيه صعبه يعاني نازحون في
مارب وتزدادوا اوضاعهم قساوه مع كل توسع
لدايره الحرب
ليت لها من اسمها نصيب هكذا تقول سعيده
المقعده في مخيم السويداء بمارب والنازحه
في دروب التعاسه منذ ثمان سنوات من حريب
نهم الى هنا مره سعيده وابنائها باربع
محطات نزوح كانت جميعها وسط نيران
الاشباكات ومع كل محطه كانت تتوفر فيها
الخدمات تصلو المقذوفات الحوثيه لتجبرهم
على تغيير مخيم النزوح وبدء معاناه جديده
حول سعيده التي اصبحت بحالها هذا المربيه
الاطفال اباءهم في الحرب اطفال لا يجدون
في خيام مم قد ما يقيهم قسوه البرد في
مناطق صحراويه مفتوحه
لي نتنافض ولا راح تضيف فوق البطانيه
كانوا كانوا فوق البطانيه من البرد من هذا
البرد اسر الحمد لله
81,000 اسره في المخيمات معرضه لموجه
البرد الشديده منها 60000 واسره بحاجه
شديده وماسه همم
لاحتياجات الايواء منها الحقائب الشتويه
ووسائل التدفئه الاخرى همم مثل البدلات
الشتويه
ومواد الايواء الفرشان والبطانيات وغيرها
من الادوات
بلد ماربو اكثر من مليونين نازحا هجرتهم
الميليشيات الحوثيه من محافظات مختلفه لكن
المعاناه الاشد هي تكرار النزوح داخليا
بين مديريات المحافظه لا تنحصر المعاناه
على مخيمات النازحين فقط فماربوا بمدينتها
واطرافها تجمع كبير لنزوح محمود الحميدي
لقناه العربيه مارب
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
في اتصال هاتفي مع الملك الاردني عبد الله
الثاني العلاقه الثنائيه بين البلدين
وتناول الاتصال ايضا بحث المستجدات
الاقليميه والدوليه والقضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك
وقفي شان الاردنيه كشف بيان والامن العام
الاردني عن تفاصيل احداث مقتلي ثلاثه من
عناصره خلال محاصره مجموعه ارهابيه
تعود الاحداث اللي تشتعل هنا من جديد فبعد
مقتل الضابط الاردني عبد الرزاق الدلابيح
بيومين داهمه القوه الامنيه القاتل هنا في
هذا البيت بمواجهه افضل لموت ثلاثه رجال
من الامن العام ومقتل قاتل الدلابيح ورغم
هدوء يعم المكان الا ان مشهد الحزن خيم
على ثلاث جنازات هنا بالتحديد تقودك
الدماء لمشهد المواجهه بين القوه الامنيه
ومجموعه من الارهابيين وما بين الرصاص
طائش وموجه قضى ثلاثه من رجال الامن العام
واصيب اخرون طبقت قواعد الاشتباك ورد
الامن بقتله احد افراد الخليه وبعد جمع
الادله الفنيه والمخبريه اكدت التحقيقات
انه هو قاتل الضابط عبد الرزاق الدلابيح
الذي قضى برصاصه اثراء اعمال شغب مفتعله
في منطقه الحسينيه ضمن عمليه ارهابيه خطط
لها لاستهدف القوات الامنيه
اليوم ليس كا البارحه
اطلب من جميع المواطنين الابتعاد عن كل
الاماكن التي تضم اعمال عنف وما بين
محافظه الطفيله ومادبا وعمان شيع
الاردنيون ثلاثه من رجال الامن وسط
مطالبات بالقصاص من الجناه من جهه والعوده
لاسباب تازم الاحداث من جهه اخرى
فردي ليس لابناء اللواء الحسينيه اي علاقه
في هذا الموضوع الحكومه
تركت المشكله من البدايه وما صار فيها
حديث مع المواطنين ولا حلت المشكله لذلك
خسرنا كانت كبيره من البدايه التصرف اللي
حدث هذا التصرف فردي ينعكس على الشخص نفسه
عدم تدخل رئيس الحكومه ومماطله الحكومه في
القضيه كامله ادت الى هذا المشهد اللي
انتم تشوفوه الان واللي الان بلشنا نخسر
ابناء سواء في الجهاز الامني او من
المواطنين احداث المواجهات الاخيره دفعت
بالقوه الامنيه لتعزيز وجودها حفاظا على
حياه المواطنين وفرض الامن خاصه مع مراري
مطالبهم في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه لا
تحتمل ذهاب الجميع الى نقطه تضيع فيها
الحقوق وتزداد فيها الاوضاع تازنا من
مدينه الحسينيه جنوب العاصمه عمان عماد
العضائله العربيه
الثانيه في البحر الميت في الاردن بمشاركه
عدد من قاده دول وسيبحث المؤتمر سبل الدعم
العراق والجهود التي يقوم بها من اجل
تعزيز امنه وسيادته وضمان استقراره وتحقيق
التنميه والرخاء لشعبه بالاضافه الى تطوير
اليات تعاون الاقليميه مع العراق في عدن
من المجالات التي تشمل مكافحه الارهاب
والامن الغذائي والامن المائي والطاقه
وغيرها من المجالات التي تسهم مفيده
التعامل الاقليميه التي تحقق التكامل
والامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
في تونس قال محاميان ان القاضي تحقيق قسم
الارهاب اصدار مذكره توقيف بحقي رئيس
الوزراء السابق والمسؤول الكبير في حزب
النهضه علي العريض وامر بسجنه الاجتماعيه
بعد ساعه من التحقيق معه
العليا
في اكثر من 130 دائره انتخابيه والغاء عدد
من النتائج الجزئيه او كليا بسبب مخالفه
بدوره على المشككين في نجاح الانتخابات
وسجل سياسيا وقانوني حول نسب المشاركه
فيها
صناديق الاقتراع تبوح باسرارها في اول
انتخابات تشريعيه بعد الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه في البلاد مجلس هيئه
الانتخابات يعلنوا ان نسبه المشاركه بلغت
11.22% وعن المرور الى دور ثاني من هذه
الانتخابات قبل تركيز البرلمان الجديد
سجلت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
قيام مليون وخمسه وعشرين الف
1418 ناخب ايامهم بحق التصويت والادلاء
باصواتهم في جميع المكاتب والمراكز بنسبه
11.22%
مجلس هيئه الانتخابات اعلن ان الدوره
الثانيه من التشريعيه سيشمل اكثر من 130
دائره انتخابيه مع تسجيل 1750 مخالفه اثرت
على سير الانتخابات الرئيس قيس سعيد رد
على المطالبين بابطال الانتخابات بالقول
ان نسبه المشاركه لا تقاس فقط بالدور
الاول بل بالدورتين معا معتبرا ان هذا
الموقف صادر عن جهات لا داب لها الا
التشكيك ليتواصل الجدل سياسيا وقانونيا
على اعتبار اهميه الاستحقاق التشريعيه في
البلاد
النخبه التونسي ذهب على مراحل في البدايه
هناك التصويت قوي بل قوي على الانتخابات
ثم ذهب نحو التصويت العقابي الذي حدث في
سنه 2014 ثم 2019 واليوم هو يذهب الى
مقاطعه هذه الانتخابات نعم وحوار الوطني
صحيحه يهم الجانب الاقتصادي والاجتماعي ثم
نتفهم ولا القاعده السياسيه الجديده
واللعبه السياسيه جديده منها القانون
الانتخابي لنجم يكون على الافراد ولكن
اسمه يتغير
وستهعلن النتائج النهائيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه في التاسعه عشر من شهر جانفي
كانون الثاني القادم بعد حسم مساله تطيعون
قضائيا واجراء الدور الثاني بدايه شهر في
افريقيا مع الاعلان عن نتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات
الى دوره ثانيه لذلك سياسيا وقانونيا رافق
العمليه خاصه وانها اخر المحطات في مشروع
الرئيس قيس سعيد لانهاء الفتره
الاستثنائيه
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
في ليبيا اكدت وزاره الخارجيه التابعه
لحكومه عبد الحميد طبيب ان تسليم المواطن
ابو عجيل مسعود المريمي لواشنطن يتنافى مع
قوانين ليبيا وفي تغريده نشرتها على
صفحتها الرسميه على موقع تويتر استنتلت
الوزاره وادانت بشده خطف ابو عجيله
وتسليمه الى واشنطن وقال ان الامر ينافي
القانون الدولي لحقوق الانسان اكدت على
ضروره مباشره الجهه القانونيه تحقيق في
الحادثه والاعلان عن النتائج باسرع ما
يمكن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق لجنه التحقيق
النيابيه في الهجوم على
منعه من الترشح للانتخابات
لملاحقته هي على غرار محاكمه عزله ومحاوله
ومحاوله
استراتيجيه اليابان الامنيه الجديده
اليابان العسكريه
كشف بنك انجلترا نقاب عن اوراق جديده
بالجنيه الاسترليني مع صوره الملك
البريطاني تشاوز الثالث والتي من المتوقع
ان يتم تداولها في منتصف عام 2024 اضاف
البنك انه ستتم طباعته الاوراق النقديه
الجديده بقيمه خمسه جنيهات وعشره جنيهات
وعشرين جنيه و50 جنيها استرلينيا فقط
تظاهرات الليليه في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه وادرامنار بمقر للبسيج في قم
وتن يقر بصعوبه الوضع في المناطق التي
ضمتها روسيا وايران تعترف بارسال مسيرات
الى موسكو قبل الحرب
صواريخ اسرائيليات تستهدف مستودع اسلحه
لميليشيه حزب الله بمحيطه مطار دمشق
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]